[Applaudissements]
les invendus après les cantonales
soirée festive une soirée romantique
avec cyril danse de l'épaule et patrick
sébastien en fond sonore
ou bien c'est une soirée laxatifs ça le
fait chier c'est vraiment pas son pays
il pleurait romantique c'est lucratif
festif ou laxatifs pour lui festif
je vais pas bien alors je vais vous dire
c'est quelqu'un qui était toujours aux
mains
oui mieux alors je connais très bien un
ton mec en soit ces choix ah ben je me
suis dit mais il est ce soir bonsoir
bonsoir faire c'est la famille ça voilà
non alors n 1 elle peut pas la chasse
que là ce sont des collèges connaissent
il ya les gens s'embrassent pas élevé
sur le plateau la médiation des îles ce
monde d'échecs petit peu comme ça voilà
qui est trop dangereux pour omission si
tu changes d'éclipsé ça surtout mes
mollets a sauté avec un des deux tu dois
j'ai imaginé ça à l'essai de marty
deuxième question pour christophe sur
thierry christophe sur thierry c'est
arrivé comme ça on fera la question là
parce que moi qui sors de pas la pécho
donc je me suis la dernière était un
journal lequel serait-il pas remis à le
journal de mickey ça reste très enfantin
[Rires]
ça serait les échos il balance que des
chiffres cohérents bien ça serait métro
le fini en moins de deux minutes sa vie
sexuelle
le deuxième le vice et les échos non le
deuxième la presse